okay Arthur wrote in saying what
characteristics are important for a
journalist to have I think there's two
sets of answers to that question one is
what skills are useful 2 is what traits
are useful as far as those do traits
first certainly curiosity a desire for
the truth to the extent that it's
knowable and I think honesty as well as
perseverance are really important traits
for a journalist to have because if you
don't have those things you're I think
Pat going to lack the basics that one
would need to even have sort of an
impetus for doing a good job when it
comes to journalism and again what we do
is not journalism in the sense of
reporting but a lot of the same
attributes and processes I think apply
and doing commentary as in doing
reporting but journalism broadly I think
those traits stick out to me is really
important I think it's a lot like being
a scientist honestly because you may
have a hypothesis as to where this the
story is going to go and you may have
you know your own perspective on the
idea and you have all these
circumstantial facts that lead you in
one way or another at the beginning of
the story but you have to be both
open-minded and honest so that if you're
interviewing someone and you find out
new relevant pieces to the investigation
you're willing to change your mind and
your perspective of where you're going
to take that story so I think that's a
pretty good comparison what you're
saying is not only good for the traits
part but it does also relate to the
skills part and I think it is important
for reporters journalists commentators
whatever to have some understanding of
the more broad sort of universe in which
you are reporting so with science this
is a really big thing science reporters
should have some background in science
now I don't mean that you need to have a
science degree I mean they need to have
a background in science reporting and
I've been going out of my way to learn
more about really important aspects of
science reporting this includes
being better at understanding
when you read about a study that's been
done some of the basics that you want to
be looking at ranging from what was the
sample size and interpreting results to
also going not falling for headlines
that sum up what a potential study may
have uncovered there's a lot that goes
into science reporting I'm not
exclusively a science reporter so I'm
not as in it as an exclusive science
reporter would be this also relates to
other skills that you need I mean can we
deny Pat that depending on what format
of reporting or commentary you do you
need to be proficient with that means of
communication whether it's voice for
radio being in front of a camera and a
microphone if it's television writing if
you're doing written reporting I mean I
think that it's sort of obvious but I
think it still bears mentioning right
and you also have to have some
experience and just background and what
you're talking about because especially
if you're going out and doing interviews
a lot of people will try to pull the
wool over your eyes and you have to be
able to be one step ahead of them and
know what right may possibly say so you
can respond in an appropriate fashion
the as far as other skills
I mean increasingly you need some tech
skills because so much of even if you're
going out and talking to someone in
person you may be writing everything
down but more than likely if for
accuracy you're going to be recording
what it is that you're doing I know this
isn't something everybody does and it
makes some interviewees uncomfortable so
you may not always do it a lot of
reporting is being done merely through
the internet so having good facility
with the tools that are being used but
these are just sort of obvious things I
think the key one is being skilled a it
to some degree in the the area or
knowledgeable in the area in which
you're reporting but I think that a lot
of the actual skills that are important
for reporting and journalism are learn
about a lot of them are learn about the
traits that will make a good journalist
I think are less learn about and I think
that that's something that that is
really important to recognize